What would happen if somebody just
handed you three strange magic cards and
asked you to build a commander deck
around them? Could you do it? Recently,
I asked my patrons what cards they
wanted to see me play in a deck. And
then I ran a poll to decide the three
I'd be building with. The results, the
S6 ceremony, Aether Vile, and Birthing
Ritual. The S6 ceremony was the card
that by far the most people wanted to
see. And this Tarker Dragon Storm
enchantment makes all of our creatures
cost two colorless less, but destroys
them when they enter. if we cast them,
replacing them with a zombie. This is
definitely a big downside, but the
silver lining here is that the two other
cards offer ways to get quizers into
play without casting them. Birthing
ritual is a two- mana enchantment that
offers a sort of limited birthing pot
effect, letting us look at the top seven
cards of our library on each endstep and
sacrifice a creature to replace it with
one from those cards. Ether Vile is a
much older card, a one mana artifact
that can gain a counter on our upkeep
and which taps to put a creature with
mana value equal to the number of
counters on it into play. So where to
start here? For one, we're in at least
Golgari colors and with a triple black
on the S6 ceremony, we're going to be
hardressed to push too far beyond that
without some herborg oriented
assistance. All three of these cards
care about creatures and some of them
care about creatures kind of a lot.
Birthing ritual is probably the lowest
commitment card here. It has a low mana
cost, relatively flexible criteria for
potting things, and you get to see all
your options before sacrificing. Really,
the only thing this needs to work well
is a moderately large creature count,
though, it can also help to have a
decent spread between mana values to
allow stairstepping up in mana costs.
Speaking of which, let's talk about
Eether. It's a card traditionally played
in heavily creature-based decks with
relatively low average mana values.
Typically, you drop it early, get it up
to two or three counters, and then pop
out extra dudes at instant speed for the
rest of the game. This makes sense in a
fast 60 card deck, but what about in an
EDH deck? The effect of deploying
creatures more rapidly isn't such a
guaranteed benefit in the slower,
typically higher curved EDH format. The
card also doesn't do anything
immediately after played, which
certainly doesn't spell success for a
card in EDH, but maybe there's a niche
for it. It's still a lowcost card and
the instant speed might be useful in
some instances. Like birthing ritual,
this card is going to be looking for a
high creature count to be useful and
preferably a relatively low average mana
cost among those creatures so that the
card is actually able to feel impactful
in the first couple turns after it's
been played. The most challenging thing
here is definitely the SIC ceremony, and
that's because it comes with a fat
downside. Your creatures literally get
destroyed as soon as they enter. Among
the five commanders this currently sees
significant play in, none include green.
So, we're going to have to get creative
here. One of the issues in commander
selection is that even if a commander
works well once it's on the board with
Sip Sig in play, you're constrained to
playing the commander before the
enchantment. And if your commander ever
gets removed, Sibig is going to make it
tricky to get back onto board. This
isn't to say there are no solutions to
this, though. Indestructible works since
Sibig destroys the creatures rather than
making you sacrifice them. And this
leaves a handful of options such as
sapling of Kulanor, Cotis, most gods,
and any partner pair that includes
Anara. There are also other commanders
that can be made to have indestructible
if you build them right. The mopplasm
can copy a creature with indestructible,
and Indoraptor will likewise be
indestructible if you have an
indestructible creature to discard. You
could also run some cards in the 99 that
regenerate a creature or return it to
play when it dies, pull a scam on your
opponents. But what about the final
option, the forbidden option? What if
your commander wants to die? This brings
me to my choice of champion,
Ename. This is a 12- mana 88 that if
played from hand, tutors out a spirit
into play when it enters and recurs a
spirit to play when it dies. But what
sorts of spirits might you want to tutor
and recur? Well, how about
Ename? Here's the default plan when we
cast our commander from hand with the
Sipstick Ceremony in play. Ename is one.
enters. Two triggers go on the stack.
One to destroy it, the other to tutor
out a spirit. We choose to resolve the
spirit searching first and tutor out
ename death aspect. When this card
enters, it searches our library for any
number of spirits and puts them into our
graveyard. We put whichever spirits we
like into our graveyard with one of them
being ename aspect. Now the sipstick
trigger on ename resolves and it dies
creating a zombie. And then this death
trigger happens putting enamepect back
into play. Now, what happens from here?
Honestly, could be a lot of things, but
ideally, if life aspect is indeed your
choice to recur, you've got some way or
other to sacrifice it. One of these
would be birthing ritual, but there are
several others. Illuminor Saras can
sacrifice this iname for mana. Greater
good can draw some cards. He who hungers
can force an opponent to discard
something, and so on. 10 cards in total.
This might seem like a lot of sacrifice
just to enable one single element of our
plan, but something I noticed early on
in building is that sacrifice outlets
are actually pretty sweet with the S6
ceremony in general because it destroys
the creatures. So, you've got all these
creatures that are going to die anyway,
and you may as well sacrifice them and
get something out of them. There are
even some things that care about power
or mana value, and for those,
sacrificing Ename itself can be a
fantastic power burst in an already big
turn. In some sense, this game plan may
seem like a combo, but in truth, having
as many of its spirits in hand as it
wants does not win the game. It
certainly makes it easier and will lead
to rapid victory sometimes with the
right prerequisites, but I didn't feel
like hammering this deck's commander
plan into a consistent win for reasons
that may become clear a bit later. No,
instead, this deck is a patchwork of
different payoffs and windcons that
align with the central pillars of this
deck that we've laid out. First off,
there's a perfectly adequate spirits
mid-range plan. A couple Miojin exist as
top-end indestructible threats, one of
which being Mojin of Life's Web that can
dump a loaded hand onto the board in
short order. There are also several
spirits with effects that happen when
spirit or arcane cards are played.
Infernal Kieran strips out opposing
hands. Kodama of the south tree pumps
our board, zombies included, and kodama
of the east tree can allow for quicker
deployment of spirits. Getting these out
safely with the Sibstix ceremony in play
can be tricky, but there are a few
options. One of these would be to
regenerate a creature with a cursed
dunyard, and another would be to use the
front side of Malacher Rebirth or
Revitalizing Rift Pass to keep the
creature in question alive. The final
option is Ether Vile. Though this deck
doesn't fit the conventional mana curve
of an ether vile deck, it is at least
somewhat predictable in what spirits it
will have available and can plan ahead
to have a certain number of counters for
a pivotal turn based on what seems like
will be the best play. The other major
option for a windcon here is the lands
package. And this actually came about
quite organically. First, a number of
specific lands really help out with our
game plan. Herborg for casting the
Sipstick Ceremony, Relicory Tower for
holding a fat hand of spirits, a cursed
dunyard for getting around the Sibic
ceremony, Command Beacon for getting
Ename into hand, and a few second tier
lands as well. In addition, a number of
cards that naturally fit into the deck
just inherently work well with a lands
package. Kura is a classic lands card
that's also a spirit with a death
trigger. White of the Reoquary is a
lovely sackability zombie, and Spirit of
the Algard is a friendly bear who can
find us a dark depths. So, here in lies
the final windcon. Field of the dead can
get us even more zombies. Dark depths
can do its dark and depthy things. And a
couple mainlands can swing real big as a
result of this deck's strange quirks.
So, that's how this deck tries to run to
the finish line, but it would be a
little unfair for me to not talk about
the setup steps. Like, sure, for some
decks, you can start the game plan at
casting the commander, but getting to
that point is in this case a bit of a
herculean task. The card is 12 mana and
relevantly we need to get it into our
hand before playing it. The ETB doesn't
happen if we cast it from the command
zone. So, let's start there. In this
deck, there are four cards that allow
for getting our commander out of the
command zone. Campfire, netherbborne
alter, road of return, and command
beacon. And getting one of these will
naturally be a requirement for any sort
of commander-based gameplay, unless
we're real down bad for a recursion
spell. Next up, the 12 mana part. That's
a lot of mana, but thankfully there's a
decent amount of highc caliber ramp that
slots nicely into this deck. There are
several ramp sources that are spirits as
well, and these include a handful of
spirit or arcane effect cards from the
original Kamagawa, as well as cryptast,
which is a fantastic card if we can get
herborg into play. Joining these is
Illumineras and Sulvi Adnate, which we'd
prefer to use on one of the ename to get
a massive surge of mana, but these can
also help build up to a commander cast
in a pinch as well. Finally, there are a
few other ramp cards that just happen to
be lovely in this particular deck with
those including Enduring Vitality,
Seance Board, and the affforementioned
White of the Reoquary. Joining these is
a decent draw suite as well. 14 cards if
I include Birthing Ritual among them,
which I am choosing to do. And if you
have issues with that, I recommend you
leave a comment telling me all about it.
Many of these are quite large scale
draw, drawing potentially five or more
cards given average circumstances. And
my hope is that pairing this with the
similarly potent ramp suite should allow
the deck to consistently climb in mana
and get where it needs to go. I'm also
running four tutors to find the Sipstick
Ceremony or other key pieces, which
isn't a massive number, but should be
enough with the other draw present. In
the ideal world, I'd love to go even a
little bit higher with each of these
values. But one thing this deck doesn't
have is a lot of extra space to work
with. I'm already spending a bunch of
slots just making my questionable
commander even functional. and adding
more draw and ramp would inevitably end
up eating to something else. My amount
of interaction is already lower than I'd
like. So, the only way to make more
space would be to cut spirits, which
would weaken my spirit synergy cards and
give me fewer options once I'm doing
Iname oriented things. Ultimately, the
version of this list I have right now
seems decently enough balanced between
its different goals. Able to play as a
sort of aristocraty spirit mid-range
deck, but also able to make some big
plays with its commander once a handful
of different conditions are met. It
could be cool to do a variant on this
deck that emphasizes a different part of
the game plan more heavily. But with
this deck, I think I've constructed a
pretty reasonable middle- of the road
approach. However, this process left me
wondering what else could be done with
these three cards I built a deck around.
So, I challenged a few other content
creators to make a deck with the same
prompt, and they rose to the challenge.
The trinket mage made a Cody Viciferous
Codeex donate deck where the goal is to
donate pesky permanence to opponents
such as the Sibic ceremony, steel golem,
or even Cody itself. There's also some
amount of permanent swapping, theft, and
threaten effects here. And birthing
ritual exists to sacrifice a threatened
creature before it could return to its
owner's control. Free three elk made a
ball lord of murder counter manipulation
and graveyard nonsense deck. Birthing
ritual is great all around in this sort
of shell. Aether Val can get combo
pieces deployed for explosive turns. And
the Sipstick Ceremony is used alongside
cheap colorless creatures to fuel
evolution witness creature looping
combos. This is a different approach
than I took and there's less broad
synergy with the Sipstick Ceremony, but
much more explosive combo potential with
it. Quips and Guac also picked out
Forgotten Realms God. Merkel, Lord of
Bones. This card is pretty neat with
Sipix Ceremony because when it destroys
your creatures, they simply come back as
enchantments. Merkel also has an
indestructible clause, so there's a
decent chance of being able to get it
back out at some point if it gets
deleted with the C6 ceremony on board.
And this deck packs a whole lot of ramp
to pay for expensive plays with its
commander. Arcosa built a Tai combo
deck. Ether Vile and Birthing Ritual are
solid here since a large portion of the
deck is one to three mana creatures, and
the Sipstick Ceremony helps out with
multiple of the deck's combo lines.
Gravequaler definitely stands out as a
card the Cypic Ceremony really works
well alongside since it provides a
zombie and doubles the amount of
potential sack triggers per cast. Blood
artist built a sultai mid-range deck
around teal the balanced scale. This is
a heavily creaturebased deck to support
birthing ritual and ether vile and we
can see a number of coolic ceremony
interactions here. Lots of sack outlets,
lots of ETBs and death abilities, a ton
of recursion for looping ETB and death
abilities, and a number of leaving
graveyard payoffs for generating value
all in the process. Thanks to these five
for taking a crack at this. I love all
the cool ideas here. And honestly, I'm
sure there are plenty of other neat
ideas out there, too. Let me know in the
comments if you have any thoughts of
what to do with these three cards. I do
actually read them, and I love hearing
all sorts of creative thoughts from
people. With that said, thanks for
watching, and thanks to Architect for
supporting the channel. I'm always so
glad to be an architect user when I'm
building highly conceptual decks like
this due to all of its great features
for analyzing what I'm building. With a
two-cond little search, I can isolate
the spirits in the deck and look at just
those cards to see what's there, both in
my main board and in my baby board. A
link to this deck is down in the
description. I also want to thank my
patrons, some of whom are on screen now.
If you want to support what I do on this
channel, a link to my Patreon is down in
the description. Finally, I was on an
episode of Extra Returns that recently
released.